Speaker 1: Did you miss me?
Speaker 1: Judging by the way the board's lit up, I'd say you couldn't live without
Speaker 1: me.
Speaker 1: You make me feel so desirable, LA.
Speaker 1: So many callers, so little time.
Speaker 1: If you don't get through to me tonight, don't let it break your heart.
Speaker 1: I'm here each and every AM, so keep dialing those magic numbers and just
Speaker 1: maybe you'll be as lucky as this caller.
Speaker 1: What's your name, night owl?
Speaker 2: Hello, Deb.
Speaker 2: This is Greg.
Speaker 1: Hello, Greg.
Speaker 1: Up late, aren't we?
Speaker 2: Well, there Deb, I work a night shift here at the power plant pretty
Speaker 2: much alone, and only thing that gets me through this shift is your pretty
Speaker 2: little voice.
Speaker 1: Thank you, Greg.
Speaker 2: Why, I imagine if you was half as pretty as your voice, then, uh,
Speaker 2: you're the prettiest woman in the city.
Speaker 1: Aren't you the gentleman?
Speaker 2: I imagine you a lot, Deb.
Speaker 2: Like I said, I'm all by myself, and it does get lonely.
Speaker 2: Sometimes a man can't help himself, uh, especially when I hear you.
Speaker 2: It's like you're here straddling my-
Speaker 1: Greg, there's a little thing called too much information.
Speaker 1: Caller, you're whiling away the evening with the Deb of Night.
Speaker 3: Good evening, Deb.
Speaker 1: Yes, I think that's implied by the title of the show.
Speaker 3: [laughs] Do you ever worry, Deb, that
Speaker 3: the world is going to end?
Speaker 1: I haven't felt that way since Brad Pitt got married.
Speaker 3: [laughs]
Speaker 3: Do you have any idea how insignificant you are?
Speaker 3: When they start devouring the world, you will be but a blood stain on
Speaker 3: their capes.
Speaker 1: I bet you say that to all the girls.
Speaker 3: There is a red star in the night sky.
Speaker 3: The blood of mortals and the blood of ages all will be consumed.
Speaker 3: They are coming.
Speaker 3: These are the final nights.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 1: Well, good luck in the next election, Senator.
Speaker 1: Apologies to all you night owls out there, but this girl's got something she's
Speaker 1: got to take care of for the next few minutes.
Speaker 1: Here's a little music to keep you up, if you get my meaning.
Speaker 4: [horn honks] Bill's here, gotta run.
Speaker 4: Great breakfast, honey.
Speaker 5: Have a good day, dear.
Speaker 5: I'm glad you liked the muffins.
Speaker 4: Hey, what's that on the counter?
Speaker 4: That's not my margarine, that's butter.
Speaker 5: It's- [slaps]
Speaker 4: Bitch, you know I'm supposed to watch my LDL levels.
Speaker 5: [cries] I, I thought it would be a nice change.
Speaker 5: You couldn't even tell.
Speaker 4: You don't want a divorce, you're trying to kill me.
Speaker 4: I'm glad I slept with your sister.
Speaker 4: [door slams]
Speaker 6: I thought it was margarine, great be butter.
Speaker 6: Other ants a taste of margarine with all the saturated fat of butter.
Speaker 7: You are on fire, Bill.
Speaker 8: I finally took your advice, and you were right.
Speaker 8: I feel more confident than ever.
Speaker 7: You the man.
Speaker 7: Isn't it great?
Speaker 8: I couldn't even believe it.
Speaker 8: We went out to dinner, and afterwards we started getting busy.
Speaker 8: I went into the bathroom to take it.
Speaker 8: I could feel it right away.
Speaker 8: Hell, you could see the title change in the toilet bowl.
Speaker 6: Vivizotrac, for when ordinary drug-enhanced erection just isn't enough.
Speaker 6: Common side effects include fainting, tingling in extremities, temporary blindness, deathly pallor, time perception
Speaker 6: distortions, aggravated bladder syndrome, emotional incest, pronounced incontinence, delusions of grandeur, and elevated risk
Speaker 6: of stroke.
Speaker 2: Grandpa, will you take me to Space Burger?
Speaker 9: Space Burger, huh?
Speaker 9: You know, when I was your age, space was mostly a mystery.
Speaker 9: We didn't know what was up there.
Speaker 9: Why, I thought there were little alien kids on Mars that might be watching
Speaker 9: me.
Speaker 9: Yeah, I used to make signs for them saying, "Hello, Martians," or, "Give me
Speaker 9: a ride on your rocket craft." Of course, I was young and naive thinking
Speaker 9: Martians could read English.
Speaker 9: [laughs] Everyone knew Martians communicated telepathically through space operators on their moon base.
Speaker 5: Billy, what did I tell you about talking to Grandpa?
Speaker 2: But I wanna go to Space Burger.
Speaker 5: Space Burger?
Speaker 5: This looks like a job for Commander Mom.
Speaker 5: Report to the space van.
Speaker 2: Oh, boy.
Speaker 5: We can drop Grandpa off at the home on the way there.
Speaker 9: Of course you don't see Martians on space probes.
Speaker 9: [laughs] Everyone knows Martians live in invisible domes.
Speaker 6: Space Burger, food for the space age, not old age.
Speaker 6: Last year, Democratic candidate Michael Rebens bought a sports utility vehicle.
Speaker 6: Three months later, there were two separate incidences of hit-and-runs by an unidentified SUV
Speaker 6: in his area.
Speaker 6: Is Democratic candidate Michael Rebens to blame?
Speaker 6: Can you afford to take that chance?
Speaker 6: Can your children?
Speaker 6: Vote Republican Senator Robert Thorne, a candidate that has never committed vehicular homicide.
Speaker 6: Democratic candidate Michael Rebens has never publicly stated his opinion on child pornography.
Speaker 6: Is it because he's hiding something?
Speaker 6: Would you want a child pornographer voting on this nation's laws?
Speaker 6: Would you trust your children's future to someone like that?
Speaker 6: Vote Republican Senator Robert Thorne, the candidate that is committed to locking up child
Speaker 6: pornographers.
Speaker 6: Democratic candidate Michael Rebens recently sued Senator Robert Thorne for accusing Rebens of being
Speaker 6: a murderous child pornographer, but Rebens had previously said he was against clogging up
Speaker 6: courts with frivolous lawsuits.
Speaker 6: Wouldn't this make him a hypocrite?
Speaker 6: Would you want a hypocrite as your next congressman?
Speaker 6: Would you want your children to become hypocrites?
Speaker 6: Vote Republican Senator Robert Thorne, a candidate not accused of being a murderous child
Speaker 6: pornographer.
Speaker 6: Money troubles and need cash quick?
Speaker 6: Why not try mugging someone?
Speaker 6: These are exactly the kind of questions the criminals are asking themselves right now.
Speaker 6: Did you know that the government requires you to wait ten days for a
Speaker 6: gun?
Speaker 6: Why, in that time, a criminal could kill your family fifty times over.
Speaker 6: So how does a law-abiding citizen like yourself get a theft-deterrent system in their
Speaker 6: hands in the next hour?
Speaker 6: Come to Loophole Lenny's.
Speaker 6: We've got antique military weaponry from blunderbusses to World War I grenades.
Speaker 6: Modern muggers may be stronger and faster than they used to be, but that
Speaker 6: doesn't mean they can take a slug fired by a Civil War-era pistol any
Speaker 6: better.
Speaker 6: And if you're the kind of person that can't sleep at night knowing serial
Speaker 6: rapists might be in your front yard, we've got German sniper rifles approved by
Speaker 6: the Kaiser himself that'll make picking them off one by one from the safety
Speaker 6: of your roof no problem.
Speaker 6: Buy a weapon this month and we'll throw in an ammo belt with the
Speaker 6: Constitution printed on it free of charge.
Speaker 6: Loophole Lenny's, defending your tomorrow with the weapons of yesterday, today.
Speaker 7: Aw, would you look at this?
Speaker 1: What's that?
Speaker 7: Plague of locusts descend on small Indian town.
Speaker 1: Jeez, I can't imagine what that must be like.
Speaker 7: And look at this.
Speaker 7: Civil war still raging between ethnic factions in Eastern Europe.
Speaker 1: Yeah, heard about that.
Speaker 7: And in Zimbabwe, they got to use ox carts for ambulances.
Speaker 1: That's terrible.
Speaker 1: Hey, it's a good thing we live in the US.
Speaker 7: It sure is, buddy.
Speaker 7: Hey, bartender, two more US ales.
Speaker 6: US Ale.
Speaker 6: Welcome to the United States of Inebriation